para empezar este vídeo vamos a
considerar un conjunto de vectores
digamos b1 b2 y así sucesivamente hasta
el vector bk pero que este conjunto de
vectores sean una base una base de un
sub espacio b y por supuesto del sub
espacio b pues será el espacio generado
por estos vectores el hecho de que sea
una base significa de entrada que ya son
linealmente independientes y eso lo
vamos a estar utilizando mucho entonces
la lo que hemos estado viendo en vídeos
anteriores es que es muy conveniente
tener bases
orton normales entonces si este conjunto
de vectores no fuera una base [ __ ]
normal digo es una base pero quizás no
son ortogonales entre ellos o quizás no
tienen norma 1 qué sé yo la pregunta es
podemos construir a partir de esta base
que ya tenemos una base [ __ ] normal y
bueno estaba cierto normal por supuesto
será de nuestro sub espacio b y vamos a
tratar de beneficiarnos de todas las
bondades que tienen estas bases [ __ ]
normales así que veamos qué podemos
hacer
vamos a empezar con un caso muy especial
el caso en que tenemos un espacio
vectorial de dimensión 1 digamos que es
el espacio vectorial generado por el
vector b 1 ok
tenemos este espacio vectorial entonces
si sabemos que es una base de este
espacio vectorial pues es b 1 y ese y
esa base es ortogonal es decir si nos
tomamos dos elementos distintos deben
ser ortogonales pero como sólo hay uno
pues ve uno es ortogonal al resto y eso
ortogonal al resto pues porque no hay
otros verdad entonces este conjunto
formado por el b uno ya es ortogonal lo
único que tenemos que construir para que
sea [ __ ] normal es que este vector tenga
norma 1 y para eso vamos a definir un
vector 1 de la siguiente forma de 1
sobre la norma debe 1 ya hemos utilizado
este truco muchísimas veces y esto lo
que nos resulta es que la norma de 1
va a ser déjenme ponerlo así la norma
debe uno sobre la norma debe uno
verdad entonces como esta norma es un
escalar esto puede salir fácilmente de
este de esta de esta norma y entonces me
queda uno entre la norma de v1 por la
norma de b1 que estos se cancelan al
multiplicar si nos da 1 entonces
finalmente el conjunto formado
únicamente por el vector 1 ya es una
base ya es una base una base de nuestro
psuv espacio de uno entonces este caso
en donde k es igual a 1 es decir sólo
tenemos un vector es muy sencillo es muy
triviales
es muy fácil ok ahora vamos a subirle un
poquito la dificultad y vamos a suponer
que tenemos un espacio vectorial de
dimensión 2 es decir que es un espacio
vectorial generado por b 1
y por dedos ok pero fíjense muy bien de
uno que es el espacio generado por ve
uno es el mismo espacio generado por un
uno verdad pues es una base de uno
entonces
esencialmente todo lo que yo pueda
generar con b1 lo puedo generar con uno
solo es cosa de multiplicar por alguna
constante distinta verdad fíjense que
aquí es de uno dividido entre su norma
entonces basta con que multiplicamos por
algún número particular por ejemplo de
hecho por la norma de de uno para que
podamos generar esencialmente los mismos
vectores entonces este espacio vectorial
que va a ser exactamente igual al
espacio vectorial generado ya no por ver
uno sino por uno por el argumento que
vimos hace unos momentos y también por
el por el vector de dos muy bien
entonces fíjense muy bien qué es lo que
está ocurriendo aquí tenemos aquí vamos
a tener nuestro vector
digamos que aquí anda
y este este uno genera a toda esta línea
verdad toda esta línea es generada por
el vector
ahí está mi línea por otro lado tenemos
al vector de dos digamos que aquí está
el vector de 2
este es el vector de 2
es el vector b2 y lo que queremos ahora
es reemplazar este b 2 pero que sea una
combinación lineal o más bien quiero
reemplazar de 2 de tal suerte que siga
generando nuestro espacio b 2 pero que
por el vector por el que reemplace sea
ortogonal a un 1 entonces de aquí del
dibujo podemos ver muy bien que
podríamos construir este vector verdad
este otro vector que digamos este este
vector es ortogonal a uno de hecho es
ortogonal a toda esta línea y eso porque
sabemos que si existe bueno sabemos que
ve dos por estar en r
en rn b 2 lo podemos escribir como la
suma de dos vectores verdad x + donde
donde nuestro vector x se encuentra en
el espacio
y el el vector que se encuentra en el
complemento ortogonal cups s parece
ortogonal el complemento ortogonal debe
1 entonces si nosotros reemplazamos este
vector de aquí que es el ok todo esto
todo esto será nuestro vector x
si nosotros reemplazamos por ave 2 vamos
a seguir generando a todo el espacio
fíjense muy bien porque de 2 es este x
que esencialmente es un múltiplo de 1
entonces este x está en el espacio
vectorial generado por uno y luego le
sumamos entonces b 2 lo expresamos como
la suma de estos dos pero como un 1 y de
2 generaban a todo el espacio b 2 pues
también un 1 y llevan a generar a todo
el espacio b 2 y déjenme ponerle aquí
llegó solo para que vayamos con con la
misma línea que vamos a ir trabajando
durante todo el vídeo entonces espero
haya quedado muy claro que como en
general
en si yo puedo generar todo todo el
espacio vectorial con b 2 y con 1 y como
b 2 es la suma de un múltiplo de 12 pues
entonces puedo generar todo con uno y
con ye 2 ok entonces sabemos además
quién es cada quien
en este juego porque ya 2 de hecho
sabemos que 2 es más bien x es la
proyección x déjenme déjenme ponerlo de
este lado
de 272 dedos es igual a y b 2 - x pero
quien es x pues x es la proyección de v2
sobre este espacio vectorial entonces es
la proyección sobre b 1 de nuestro
vector b 2 muy bien entonces si ya
tenemos esta expresión este g 2 lo que
nos va a dar es una base ortogonal
todavía no está normalizado por al menos
ortogonal verdad y de hecho podemos
calcular muy bien quién es la proyección
sobre b b1 b2 y eso es porque en b1
tenemos ya una base tiene una base
base
[ __ ] normal corto normal y eso lo
sabemos muy bien verdad de hecho vamos a
escribirlo de este lado tenemos que la
proyección la proyección sobre b1 de
nuestro vector b 2 es igual
fíjense muy bien tenemos que la
proyección la proyección como es un
elemento debe uno simplemente va a ser
de dos punto de uno a uno
por un 1 verdad esto lo vimos hace ya
algunos vídeos cuando vimos bases [ __ ]
normales que podíamos expresar lo de
esta forma ok entonces esta proyección
ya la tenemos así que finalmente tenemos
que 2 va a ser igual a b2 b2 aquí
tenemos de dos verdades b 2 menos esta
proyección esta proyección fue de 2.11
por 11 muy bien entonces ahora sólo me
falta definir un último vector para que
esto sea normalizado
entonces vamos a definir el vector 2
como 2 sobre su norma exactamente igual
que lo hicimos en el caso anterior
verdad y este por supuesto ya tiene
norma unitaria ya tiene la norma de u2
es unitario y además como es un múltiplo
de ye 210 2 era ortogonal a 1
entonces 2 es ortogonal a 1 y tienen
ambos norma 1 por lo tanto éste será
igual al espacio vectorial generado por
un 1 y 2 pero además la ventaja que ya
tenemos es que estos ya forman un
espacio con una base [ __ ] normal debe 2
muy bien entonces vámonos a extender un
poquito este concepto vámonos a ahora
qué pasa si ver si si tenemos un espacio
vectorial de dimensión 3 es decir que
esté generado el espacio vectorial
generado por un 1 y un 2 ok y ahora nos
tomamos el vector de 3
muy bien
entonces en realidad podríamos haber
tenido aquí b1 y b2 pero como
esencialmente son generados por estos
vectores entonces podemos sustituirlos
ahora bien si nosotros tenemos este caso
aquí vamos a tener un plano el espacio
vectorial generado por q1 y q2 es de 2
que es un plano
y un plano
este es el espacio de dos dedos y aquí
vamos a tener por ejemplo otro vector el
b3 que como éste no se encuentra en este
espacio porque son linealmente
independientes entonces éste va a salir
volando por aquí aunque ya aquí está el
vector b 3 que no se encuentra en este
plano muy bien entonces si tenemos esto
nuevamente podemos utilizar la misma
idea este vector lo podemos descomponer
como la suma de dos vectores uno que se
encuentra en el plano aunque hay que de
hecho va a ser este verde y uno que se
encuentra en el complemento ortogonal
este verde se encuentra en el plano y el
amarillo se encuentra en el complemento
ortogonal ok entonces vamos a escribirlo
b3 esencialmente lo que nos dice es que
de 3 se puede expresar como un x3
digamos más de 3 donde x 3 se encuentra
en él
en el espacio b 2 y 3 se encuentra en el
complemento ortogonal de v2 entonces de
aquí tenemos que ye 373 es igual a b 3 -
x 3 pero x 3 que es este verde este es x
3 ok
este es una combinación lineal de un 1 y
un 2 verdad de hecho sabemos que b 3 que
perdón que x 3 es la proyección es la
proyección
sobre el espacio v2 del vector b3 ok
entonces vamos otra vez a calcular este
de aquí es la proyección la proyección
sobre b 2 del vector b 3 vamos a
calcular esto quién es la proyección
quién es la proyección del vector b 2
perdón del vector de tres sobre el sub
espacio b 2 nuevamente tenemos que esta
proyección ya sabemos calcularlo por
todo lo que hemos visto de bases [ __ ]
normales es de 3.1 que multiplica al
vector 1-1
be be 3.2 que multiplica al vector 2 que
entonces si ya tenemos quién es esta
proyección que es el vector x 3 o el
vector verde entonces ya también sabemos
quién es el vector que me interesa y 3
porque nos interesa ya 3 porque vamos a
sustituir de 3 por 3 verdad como ye 3 es
la suma de esta proyección que es una
combinación lineal de 1 y 2 y de 3
entonces todo lo que yo pueda generar
con todo lo que pueda generar con 12 ib3
se puede generar con 1 2 y 3 es verdad
hay una combinación de 1 2 y 3 que me da
b 3 entonces cualquier múltiplo de v 3
será un múltiplo de tv3 perdón de de la
combinación lineal que genera b 3 y por
eso es que son los mismos espacios
vectoriales entonces
hay tres igual a b 3 - vamos a vamos a
copiar esto de aquí
a copiarlo
voy a pegarlo entonces vamos a restarle
exactamente esto mismo
restarle esto y así es como construimos
ye 3 que es ortogonal a todo este plano
pero todavía nos falta algo porque ye 3
no necesariamente tiene norma 1 así que
simplemente volvemos a definir 13 como
de 3 sobre la norma de ye 3
y entonces este 13 ya tiene norma 1
verdad todo lo que hemos visto y este
espacio vectorial será igual al espacio
vectorial generado por uno o dos pero
ahora en vez de b3 va a ser generado por
o
por q 3 muy bien otra vez si tenemos a
b3 y es generado es tv3 es una
combinación lineal de alguien de este de
un elemento de este plano que de hecho
aquí está esta combinación lineal y
además le sumamos ye 3 es decir b 3 lo
podemos expresar como combinación lineal
de 1 2 y 3
entonces podemos generar exactamente lo
mismo que con 12 ib3 si sustituimos a b3
con ye 3 verdad entonces ya que tenemos
esto dicho si podemos seguir este
procedimiento hasta obtener uca si si
por ejemplo que fuera igual a tres ya
acabaríamos sica es igual a 4 vamos a
hacer este ejemplo
si k es igual a 4 si que es igual a 4
entonces vamos a partir de este espacio
vectorial 4 que es el espacio vectorial
generado pues esencialmente por estos
anteriores que es un 1 2 y un 3 pero
además ahora vamos a agregar el vector b
4 y nuevamente queremos sustituir b 4 de
tal suerte que tengamos aquí una base
[ __ ] normal ok y ya sabemos entonces que
nuestro vector de 4 aunque esto sea
bastante difícil de ver porque estamos
en un espacio de 4 dimensiones pero
según todo esto que hemos estado
realizando va a ser de 4 - la proyección
sobre b 3 sobre b 3 de nuestro vector de
4 ok y entonces de hecho esto esto
resulta de ver que de 4 se puede
expresar como ye 4 más la proyección
sobre b 3 desde 4 verdad era lo que
exacta era exactamente lo que teníamos
acá arriba
aquí en donde uno se encuentra en el
espacio vectorial y el otro en el
complemento ortogonal entonces de 4 es
el que está en el complemento ortogonal
y con esto con esta con esta expresión
podemos definir finalmente a un 14 como
4 sobre la norma de 4 perdón 10 4 de 4
ok y entonces sustituimos 14 por de 4 y
tenemos una base [ __ ] normal de este
espacio y vectorial generado por los
cuatro vectores entonces si seguimos
este proceso una y otra vez podemos
llegar a cualquiera que se nos ocurran
ya este procedimiento para crear una
base [ __ ] normal es llamado el proceso
el proceso de gran smith este es el
proceso
proceso de gran
smith
y este es el famoso proceso de
transmitir y puede parecer un poco
abstracto de la forma en que lo hice
aquí pero en el próximo vídeo voy a
encontrar bases [ __ ] normales de sub
espacios para que veas que no es tan
malo lidiar con números reales